el voto latino es decisivo va a ser
decisivo en esos estados también en
pensilvania a arizona texas y florida es
donde tienen las campañas puesta la
mirada aquí en florida sin embargo hay
dos grupos minoritarios que son los
cubanos y los puertorriqueños ambos
grupos más o menos hay registrados unos
650.000 votantes en esta elección y
luego hay otros grupos minoritarios como
podrían ser los venezolanos algunos se
preguntan por qué el presidente de
donald trama ha sacado a colación en
muchísimas ocasiones el tema de la
crisis en venezuela y hay que
remontarnos a hace cuatro años cuando
hillary clinton perdió el estado de
florida por tan sólo 130 mil votos esos
votos podrían acabar inclinando la
balanza hacia un lado u otro por parte
de los venezolanos u otros grupos
minoritarios de latinos o por eso
joe biden como donald trump están
intensificando su discurso en zonas como
el sur de la florida para intentar
cautivar el voto de los indecisos saben
que es muy importante sobre todo cuando
se ha tenido esa premisa de quién gane
florida va a acabar ganando la
presidencia ahora sin embargo no sé no
sé no se tiene no sé las no las tienen
todas consigo en ninguna de las dos
campañas pero pese a eso quieren seguir
asegurando el voto de los latinos así
que temas como la inmigración también la
sanidad o las políticas económicas son
temas que interesan y mucho a estas
comunidades de hecho
joe biden ha sacado a colación en más de
una ocasión el hecho de que donald trump
a pesar de que ha defendido esas
políticas de presión al gobierno de
nicolás maduro a través de las sanciones
dice que no ha ayudado a los venezolanos
que están en eeuu con órdenes ejecutivas
para darles
estatus de protección temporal por
ejemplo algo que el joe biden ha dicho
que si llega a la casa blanca lo primero
que hará una de las primeras cosas que
hará será otorgar el tps a por orden
ejecutiva así que ese voto latino es muy
importante aquí en florida algunos ya
dan por hecho que va a acabar
determinando al menos en este estado el
futuro ganador aquí en florida raúl